und jetzt das heute journal bettina
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend hinein wir
beginnen heute abend mit dem was es
sonst am ende gibt den blick auf die
wetterkarte
süd europa steht ein harter sommer bevor
das sind nicht nur die temperaturen das
hier sind die für die kommenden tage
wieder hitzewelle in spanien portugal
südfrankreich bis zu 40 grad dazu kommt
eben auch eine extreme trockenheit teile
von spanien und portugal sind so trocken
wie seit 1000 jahren nicht mehr haben us
forscher herausgefunden weil die
klimakrise das azorenhoch verändert dass
für den süden europas lebenswichtig ist
der große feind der landwirtschaft die
folgen treffen uns alle aus dem süden
europas berichten unsere korrespondentin
annette hilsenbeck und anna arbeitet
reis mais oder hirse wenn landwirt
lorenz um ist rooney dieses jahr über
seine felder in rosato in der lombardei
schaut wird ihm angst und bange nichts
wächst richtig überall fehlt wasser
alles trocken alles da wird nichts draus
gar nichts das ist sorge im hirse die zu
dieser jahreszeit theoretischen
mindestens 70 zentimeter hoch sein
müsste
nur etwa die hälfte der saudis auf dem
feld aufgegangen und dann konnte nicht
bewässert werden weil es keinen
wassergaben
beim reis sieht es nicht besser aus die
bewässerung ist streng rationiert alle
zehn tage erhält der landwirt ein
bisschen das reicht nicht lorenzo misst
roni weiß nicht ob er überhaupt reis
ernten wird dieses jahr das dürre
desaster trifft die gesamte poebene von
dem fluss ist die landwirtschaft
abhängig doch dessen pegelstand es
niedrig wie seit 70 jahren nicht mehr im
norden italiens hat es seit januar nicht
richtig geregnet dazu blieb die
schneeschmelze aus italiens regierung
hat für fünf regionen im norden den
notstand ausgerufen ihnen 36 5 millionen
euro für hilfen zur verfügung gestellt
auf die hofft auch ettore ferrari 15
weniger milch geben seine kühe wegen dem
hitzestress den versuch der mit
ventilatoren und duschen zu mildern die
viel strom verbrauchen auch sonst
steigen seinen kostenlos futter
dazukaufen
die golfkugel stalking der hitze und der
dürre wächst auf meinen feldern nichts
es gibt fast nichts zu erben
für morgen sind in teilen nord italiens
gewitter angekündigt darauf hoffen sie
doch angesichts der dürre sind die wohl
nur ein tropfen auf dem heißen stein
zusammen stehen fürs wasser die
dorfbewohner von mofair waren das
kostbare gut im rathaus und die
bürgermeisterin wird zur schatzmeisterin
bekommt jede person einen sechserpack
nein es sind zwei liter pro person pro
tag seit dem wochenende gilt in der
südfranzösischen gemeinde leitungswasser
ist tabu sogar fürs zähneputzen
der grund wegen lang anhaltende
trockenheit und hitze kann die
wasserqualität nicht mehr gewährleistet
werden
das museum die gesundheitsbehörde hat
uns aufgefordert unsere wasserspeicher
mit viel chlor zu versetzen deshalb
verteilen wir nun trinkwasser in
flaschen an die bewohner
anderenorts im hinterland der côte
d'azur siegen quellen gänzlich hier wird
das wasser per tankwagen geliefert diese
strecke fährt dämmung 37 mal am tag in
50 jahren habe ich so etwas nicht erlebt
im winter gab es keinen schnee und jetzt
keinen regen
hinzu kommen extreme temperaturen bis zu
40 grad die böden trocknen ausflüsse wie
etwa die loire führen kaum noch wasser
im dorfbach versuchen sie sich
anzupassen die kinder müssen wir jetzt
durch das rathaus wird weiter wasser
pakete an uns verteilen damit wir es
trinken können und damit kochen
das spülwasser und das badewasser das
fange ich auf und nutzen es anschließend
zum putzen
und so hangeln sie sich von tag zu tag
durch diese durststrecke müssen
durchhalten
ein ende der hitzewelle ist nicht in
sicht
ja aber mit durchhangeln von tag zu tag
kann es ja nicht getan sein der
klimaforscher mojib latif ist bei uns
neuer präsident der hamburger akademie
der wissenschaften der professor guten
abend genannt wir sehen massive schäden
für die landwirtschaft in italien in
spanien in portugal rechnen die forscher
mit verheerenden folgen für weinbau
olivenernte was steht uns da bevor ja
wir müssen leider sagen dass wir das
erleben was unsere klimamodelle schon
seit jahrzehnten
vorhergesagt haben für weiter steigende
temperaturen und
der mittelmeerraum das war immer ein
hotspot und das realisiert sich jetzt
leider und wir müssen damit rechnen dass
das hier die anfänge sind und in dem
maße www temperatur weiter steigt wir
eben noch katastrophalere bedingungen
beobachten werden obst aus italien obst
aus spanien das ist uns ja alles bereits
sehr nahe beim täglichen einkauf und das
sind ja eigentlich auch sehr fruchtbare
regionen wie es denn die lage in
deutschland auch hier gibt es ja aktuell
regionen mit extremer trockenheit gerade
im osten ja genau gerade im osten das
passt auch genau in dieses muster und
man muss einfach wissen dass bei höheren
temperaturen die verdunstung sprunghaft
ansteigt und dadurch eben die böden noch
mal schneller austrocknen und wenn die
böden trocken sind kann die temperatur
auch noch mal weiter steigen und er so
einen teufelskreis und den erleben wir
jetzt gerade im osten deutschlands
wissen wir denn überall das genug haben
wir das genug erforscht wie sich diese
niederschlagsmengen komplett anders
verteilen als in der vergangenheit und
haben wir uns gut darauf eingestellt ja
wir haben schon eine ganz gute idee
davon wie sich steigen die temperaturen
auf die niederschlagsverteilung
auswirken das heißt auf der einen seite
trockenheit ja dürre wie wir es jetzt
sehen auf der andern seite aber auch
immer wieder diese stark
niederschlagsereignisse das heißt es ist
nicht entweder oder sondern ein sowohl
als auch und insofern müssen wir auch
erkennen dass er so etwas wie grenzen
der anpassungsfähigkeit gibt man wird
sie nicht an alles anders und ich glaube
was wir gerade erleben in deutschland in
europa aber auch weltweit ist dass wir
tatsächlich diese grenzen der
anpassungsfähigkeit erleben erste
pandemie herr professor jetzt der krieg
die überlagern vieles ist denn allen
klar dass diese klimakrise eben noch mal
auf einer ganz anderen ebene spielt und
nicht verdrängt werden kann von nichts
nein da scheint immer noch nicht
angekommen zu sein
bei den langfristigen probleme wie der
klimakrise wie bei dem artensterben
haben die verantwortlichen immer das
gefühl dass man noch zeit hat aber
irgendwann läuft die zeit ab und jetzt
so langsam die zeit gekommen wo wir
eigentlich überhaupt keine zeit mehr
haben und das einzige was wirklich
helfen kann ist eine ganz ganz enge
internationale kooperation weil es
völlig egal wo gas ein gast wie co2
ausgestoßen wird es ist so langlebig
dass er sich über den erdball verteilt
und immer überall wirksam ist eine
globale gemeinsame anstrengung sagen sie
wenn man sich aber die lage aktuell
anguckt ist ja eher das gegenteil der
fall auch angesichts der vielen anderen
probleme die zur zeit zu meistern und
sind zu den eindruck jedes land werkelt
aktuell irgendwie vor sich hin in der
politik geht zwei schritte vor und dann
wieder einen zurück auf der einen seite
richtung erneuerbare energien in
deutschland aber gleichzeitig setzen wir
auch wieder notgedrungen auf kohle gas
import aus katar können sie das
verstehen vor dem hintergrund was auf
dem spiel steht oder würden sie sagen da
wird gerade eine chance vertan ja da
wird gerade eine chance vertan aber wir
haben uns tatsächlich in eine sackgasse
manövriert außer es ganz schwer
auszukommen ist wir haben jahrzehntelang
immer das falsche getan
und jetzt rächt es sich jetzt stehen wir
mit dem rücken zur wand und was wir
brauchen ist endlich eine langfristige
strategie die wir konsequent umsetzen
und noch einmal es braucht eine
internationale zusammenarbeit die im
moment gar nicht in sicht und deswegen
begrüße ich den vorschlag des
bundeskanzlers auch einen sogenannten
klima club einzurichten ich nenne es
eine allianz der willigen ich glaube wir
können nicht auf den letzten wagen
sondern jetzt vorangehen und daneben
versuchen so viele länder wie möglich in
diesem klima club einzubeziehen ganz
kurz vielleicht noch wenn ich darf es
gibt auch viele menschen die wollen
alters nicht mehr hören angesichts
dieser probleme die haben den eindruck
es gibt gar keinen ausweg ist vielleicht
eine blöde frage aber eine die sich
viele stellen gibt es ein szenario das
auch hoffnung machen kann weil der ja im
prinzip ist ja die lösung des
klimaproblems denkbar einfach wir
brauchen eine weltweite energiewende und
das schnell die möglichkeiten dazu sind
vorhanden die finanzmittel sind da geld
ist genug vorhanden es fehlt einfach der
politische wille das heißt also wir
könnten unser klima noch halbwegs im
rahmen halten wenn denn jetzt wirklich
die länder endlich den pariser
klimaabkommen auch taten folgen lassen
würden der klimaforscher mojib latif
herr professor vielen dank für das
gespräch heute abend sehr gerne
jeder eingesparte kubikmeter hilft das
ist der appell seit wochen an haushalte
und industrie seit deutschland gebannt
auf den füllstand seiner gasspeicher
guckt 80 prozent zum ersten oktober 90
prozent zum ersten november das ist das
ziel steht so auch im gesetz aber ob wir
das erreichen ist mehr als offen peter
kunz hat deutschlands energiemangel
manager den chef der bundesnetzagentur
begleitet in den größten erdgasspeicher
bei diepholz in niedersachsen
wir sagen jetzt erst mal ordentlich
hallo hier deutschlands oberster
gassmann klaus müller verwaltet den
mangel und soll ihn beseitigen
heute hat der chef der bundesnetzagentur
zum ersten mal zeigt sich deutschlands
größten gasspeicher anzusehen den seine
behörde sozusagen beschlagnahmt hat und
der derzeit auf volllast ein speichert
aber wird das alles reichen für einen
warmen winter viele offene fragen
gelingt es uns
gaskraftwerke in der verstromung
abzuschalten gelingt es uns mit einer
wahnsinns geschwindigkeit energie
thermen es an der nordseeküste in einem
ersten schritt sozusagen an zu landen
damit wir gas einsprechern können können
wir uns weiter unsere nachbarn wie
norwegen belgien holland verlassen die
gerade ganz maßgeblich dazu beitragen
unsere speicher zu befüllen alles hängt
davon ab ob nach der anstehenden kurz
abschaltung und wartung der nordstream 1
pipeline wieder gas fließen wird oder ob
moskau den hahn zugedreht lässt die
botschaften sind uneindeutig von
beruhigenden botschaften es geht wieder
zurück in einen normalzustand bis zu
alarmierenden
dramatischen botschaften es kann auch
noch weniger werden ist alles drin ich
gehe davon aus dass diese unsicherheit
gewollt ist und wir wissen schlicht
nicht was in zwei wochen passieren wird
die durch die decke schießen dem
gaspreise der bundesnetzagentur hilft
das bei ihrem unermüdlich wiederholten
sparappell der gasverbrauch vor allem in
der industrie ist schon gesunken weil
die energie einfach zu viel kostet es
ist irgendwie keine abstrakte
entscheidung gas zu sparen und ein zu
speichern es ist eine konkrete und es
gibt das gefühl in dieser krise passiv
zu sein hilflos zu sein und das ist
falsch wir sind nicht hilflos wir können
was tun die bundesregierung muss ihres
tun jedes unternehmen jeder haushalt
kann was dazu beitragen dass wir gut
durch den winter kommen durch den winter
kommen ohne notfall stufe ohne gezieltes
abkoppeln vom gasnetz nach einer
prioritätenliste
das ist der weihnachtswunsch schaute ihn
reden wo ein fünftel der deutschen
gasspeicher kapazität liegt bei 19
mitarbeiter jetzt für deutschland
arbeiten nicht mehr für das gazprom
imperium wie viele kollegen kollegen im
unternehmen gehabt mit russischen passt
mit russischen familien teilweise in der
heimat die uns trotzdem in der ganzen
april bei zeit wo spitz auf knopf stand
die treue gehalten haben und die dazu
beigetragen haben die gasversorgung in
deutschland zu sichern und für die das
ein wahnsinns zwiespalt war und die
tatsächlich auch situation hatten die
nicht leicht waren
putins krieg soll spalten aber das muss
ja nicht gelingen ein symbolbild von der
glasfront im speicher regen
man kann davon ausgehen dass auch der
bundeskanzler sich den aktuellen
füllstand der speicher jeden morgen ganz
oben auf den schreibtisch legen lässt er
weiß auch die bürgerinnen und bürger
dieses landes haben sorgen in
wirtschaftlich düsterer zeit und sie
erwarten antworten heute war
regierungsbefragung im bundestag
elisabeth schmidt er bringt eine mappe
voller themen mit energiekrise
preiskrise wirtschaftskrise die stimmung
im bundestag ist hitzig der kanzler
schwört gewohnt ruhig gleich zu beginn
auf einen nationalen kraftakt ein was
wir jetzt brauchen ist dass wir uns
unterhaken doch wie dieses unterhalten
genau aussehen soll darüber wird heftig
gestritten
energiesparen warmwasser rationieren aus
sicht der fdp ali teetz ferne politik
wie können wir den menschen in der
ukraine helfen wenn wir hier frieren ich
halte fest die afg ist nicht nur eine
rechtspopulistische partei sondern auch
die partei russlands und das sollten
alle vertretenen
schlagabtausch zur energiepolitik
hauptthema ist der drohende gas mangeln
die laufzeit der letzten drei
atomkraftwerke in deutschland verlängern
lehnt olaf scholz ab
lassen sie die drei kernkraftwerke die
noch am netz sind und grundlastfähig und
sicher in deutschland laufen nicht
befristet noch weiterlaufen wenn man die
atomkraftwerke betrachtet das was wir an
heizenergie brauchen was wir an prozess
energie für die unternehmen brauchen das
kann dadurch gar nicht ersetzt werden es
gibt also nur um einen kleinen teil der
stromproduktion
es folgt eine aktuelle stunde einberufen
durch die union sie will energie
sicherheit und inflation diskutieren
doch regierungsmitglieder nehmen daran
nicht teil
dokumentiert zugleich
ein wirklich atemberaubendes
desinteresse an den sorgen der menschen
in unserem land es ist
der versuch den kanzler per hammelsprung
abstimmung herbei zu zitieren scheitert
die forderungen nach einer
unternehmenssteuerreform herd olaf
scholz nicht mehr sie machen eine
konzertierte aktion mit dem
bundeskanzler die genauso ausgehen wird
wie die letzten konzertierten aktionen
die dauern jahre
sie sind endlose gesprächsrunden sie
sind ein alibi dafür dass sie keine
reformen in diesem lande durchsetzen
wollen was für ein absurdes theater was
sie hier spielen kein wort zu den
lieferketten kein wort zu den gaspreisen
die mit putin zusammen hängt nichts von
alledem das einzige was sich hier getan
haben ist ihre alte mottenkiste aus den
90er jahren wieder rauszuholen die alten
instrumente verstaubt einmal noch durch
den raum zu schmeißen ich muss sagen
dass ich mich mit dem verlauf der
debatte und auch wieder das ganze hier
gerade passiert ziemlich schwer tue wer
das gemacht wird das gemacht das hilft
auch den menschen überhaupt nicht die
linke prangert an den lieben haushalt an
die einhaltung der schuldenbremse hält
sie für ein märchen wir brauchen
dringend ein drittes entlastungspaket
aber schlag die bürgerinnen und bürger
zu schützen schützen sie die
schuldenbremse von christian linder zeit
zum abkühlen bieten ab nächster woche
die parlamentarischen sommerferien
fragt sich nur wie lange denn die vielen
krisen werden keine pause machen
ja so ist es wir bleiben noch moment in
der politik hanna du hast die
nachrichtenübersicht das bundeskabinett
hat den ersten teil des sogenannten
migrations pakets beschlossen neben der
ausweitung des bleiberechts und
erleichterungen bei der fachkräfte
einwanderung enthält es auch ein
sogenanntes chancen aufenthaltsrecht
dadurch sollen sich langjährig geduldete
um ein dauerhaftes bleiberecht bewerben
können
136.000 menschen könnten davon
profitieren
voraussetzung sind deutschkenntnisse ein
gesicherter lebensunterhalt und eine
nachgewiesene identität
straftäter und gefährder sind davon
ausgeschlossen sie sollen leichter
abgeschoben werden können
der hunger auf der welt bereitet sich
laut vereinten nationen weiter aus die
zahl der unterernährten ist im
vergangenen jahr auf bis zu 8 128
millionen gestiegen das zeigt der
aktuelle un bericht zur weltweiten
versorgungslager vor der korona pandemie
seien es etwa 150 millionen weniger
gewesen hauptgründe dafür seien neben
corona die folgen des klimawandels und
konflikte
beschäftigte die unter longo wird leiden
sind oft lange krankgeschrieben das
zeigt eine auswertung der techniker
krankenkasse
nach einem leichten verlauf wetten long
kurve betroffene im schnitt 90 tage
gefehlt bei patienten mit längeren
krankenhausaufenthalt seien es
durchschnittlich
168 tage gewesen zu den symptomen von
longo witt würden unter anderem
kopfschmerzen extreme müdigkeit oder
atemnot gehören
der druck auf den britischen premier
johnson steigt immer weiter nachdem zwei
wichtige minister seines kabinetts
zurückgetreten sind folgten heute
zahlreiche staatssekretäre und
konservative amtsträger bei einer
aktuellen fragestunde im parlament kam
es zu einem schlagabtausch auch
abgeordnete der tory stellten sich gegen
den premier hintergrund sind eine reihe
von skandalen
doch johnson bekräftigt ein weiteres mal
er wolle weitermachen
ja das ist keine überraschung dass sagt
er immer nachgefragt bei andreas stamm
jetzt unser mann in london einen abend
andreas wie wahrscheinlich ist es denn
dass johnson auch im amt bleiben kann
obwohl sich so viele der eigenen leute
gerade entsetzt abwenden
ja genau am griff er klammert sich
wirklich mit aller macht an dieses amt
aber dabei sind sich fast alle hier
einig alle politischen beobachter er hat
diese macht verloren selbst treueste
verbündete so heißt es sind heute hinter
mir internen downing street in seinem
amtssitz aufgeschlagen und haben gesagt
du musst zurücktreten du bringst schande
und scham über dich über die partei über
das amt das muss aufhören und in diesen
irren wendungen dieses tages war dann
eigentlich auch geplant dass die
fraktion den weg ebnet für ein weiteres
misstrauensvotum dann sind sie
umgeschwenkt haben gesagt wir geben euch
sonst noch mal bis montag zeit um
vielleicht nicht in würde der zeitpunkt
ist ein bisschen verpasst aber zumindest
aus eigenen stücken gehen zu können die
fraktion hat das daneben zurückgezogen
und jetzt sitzt boris johnson und
grübelt was soll er tun er will weiter
kämpfen und er wirkt ein wenig so wie
ein mini tramp ein label das er immer
abgelehnt hat aber es wird immer
einsamer um ihn hinter mir und herrn
downing street und die schlinge zieht
sich weiter zu und er ist abgekoppelt
von der wirklichkeit denn hier schreien
es wirklich die spatzen von den dächern
investments seinem politischen london
wie ist er ist erledigt
hat sich dank andreas stamm live aus
london heute abend
ankommen in deutschland ist zunehmend
glückssache unterwegs sein ist ein
abenteuer leider meist kein erfreuliches
wir sind stolz auf unsere autoindustrie
wir haben das größte bahnnetz europas
aber wer uns hier aus dem ausland
besucht staunt wie schwierig es ist von
a nach b zu kommen und zwar egal ob mit
fahrrad auto zug oder flugzeug
es läuft überall miserabel die deutschen
staunen längst nicht mehr die einen
haben resigniert die anderen fragen sich
wie es so weit kommen konnte und wer
dafür die verantwortung trägt klar ist
zumindest eins nämlich wer jetzt
zuständig ist dass es besser wird
bundesverkehrsminister volker wissing
hat nicht nur mit zugausfällen bei der
bahn zu tun sondern auch mit chaos in
den flughafenterminals und mit maroden
autobahnbrücken christiane hübscher hat
ihn dabei begleitet
ein typischer volker wissing termin geht
so er darf den ladestecker in das
elektroauto einstöpseln und sagen dass
er auch privat ganz elektrisiert ist
den ich versuche nur elektrisch sofort
das klappt ganz gut
laden aber muss wissen sein auto meist
noch in der eigenen garage weil auch er
die erfahrung macht draußen fehlt es an
ladesäulen überall wissen verspricht
seit monaten einen masterplan für eine
million ladepunkte aber er liefert nicht
denn fdp-mann wissing und der grüne
harbeck streiten hinter den kulissen
über energiepolitische details stehen
vor einem enormen transformationsprozess
wir haben knapper haushaltsmittel müssen
genau überlegen wofür geben wir
öffentliche gelder aus und dass man in
diesen fragen einen diskurs hat
unterschiedliche argumente abwägt und
auch intensiv diskutiert ist ja ein
gutes zeichen die automobilindustrie
aber braucht schnell klarheit von
bisschen nervös registrieren sie hier
das er synthetischen kraftstoffen eine
hintertür offen lässt die kaufprämie für
e-autos streichen will die branche
fordert mehr durchsetzungsstärke vom
verkehrsminister und minister witzig hat
eines der komplexesten ressource und ich
würde mich schon freuen wenn auch
interministeriellen mehr miteinander
gearbeitet wird um zu unterstützen wie
zb bei der ladeinfrastruktur notwendig
natürlich durch den
bundeswirtschaftsminister
es brennt an allen enden im
verkehrsbereich der minister will wie
alle seine vorgänger auch die marode
bahn retten sie zur chefsache machen
diesmal wirklich wissen feiert den
erfolg des neuen euro tickets aber kann
nicht sagen was er danach mit dem
nahverkehr vorhat ich glaube das ist der
richtige weg dass wir sagen wir
evaluieren diese drei monate und
überlegen dann was für schlüsse wir
daraus ziehen die fahrradlobby hätte
gerne eine milliarde euro pro jahr von
wissing für den radweg ausbau die sie
nicht bekommt ich glaube er mag das
fahrrad aber zur schattenseite ich
glaube das auto mag er auch und
vielleicht mag er das auto sogar ein
bisschen lieber als das fahrrad
nein ich habe empfinde gab keine
emotionen nicht damit verbinde ich
möchte jeder und jedem ein überzeugendes
mobilitätsangebot machen ich finde das
fahrrad ein tolles verkehrsmittel
vielleicht ist das wissens größtes
problem er will es allen ein bisschen
recht machen dafür kritisieren ihn
selbst ampel partner wenn man wirklich
für alle was anbieten will dann muss man
dem einfach wegnehmen was nicht
funktioniert ist so zu tun als könnte
man einfach alles nebeneinander stellen
und die leute sollen mal frei auswählen
denn der platz ist begrenzt er habe
gewusst worauf er sich einlässt als der
bundesverkehrsminister wurde so wissing
doch der start ist ruckelig noch hat
kein fertiger verkehrs gesetzentwurf
sein haus verlassen
bei der deutschen lufthansa liegen die
nerven blank die der passagiere sowieso
aber auch die mitarbeiter melden sich
heute auf einer krisensitzung des
aufsichtsrats mit massiver kritik am
pandemie und personalmanagement des
vorstandschefs sie berichten von
gesundheitlichen belastungen von
check-in mitarbeitern die von der
polizei vor aufgebrachten reisenden
geschützt werden müssen am drehkreuz
frankfurt sind gerade mal noch 26
prozent der lh flüge pünktlich
fast drei viertel sind es nicht da ist
wirklich was ins trudeln geraten und die
große sommerreisewelle die kommt ja erst
noch
hier bei uns kommt jetzt noch mal hanna
mit weiteren meldungen aus der
wirtschaft und da blicken wir auf eine
durchaus umstrittenen entscheidung die
das eu parlament heute getroffen hat
investitionen in erdgas- und atomkraft
sollen künftig als nachhaltig eingestuft
werden es geht um die sogenannte
taxonomie regel die ab 2023 greifen soll
und eine blockade durch die
mitgliedstaaten gilt als ausgeschlossen
fragen wir nach bei frank bethmann
welche folgen hat diese einstufung dann
genau letztendlich gibt diese taxonomie
den finanzmärkten vor was grün ist und
was nicht was als nachhaltige
technologie und energiequelle gilt denn
in diese bereiche soll er künftig
verstärkt das geld der investoren
fließen investitionen in atomkraftwerke
sind mit dieser entscheidung heute
genauso wie in windkraft- oder
solaranlage einer logik der aber längst
nicht alle folgen wollen ingo speich
fondsmanager von der sparkassentochter
deka investment positioniert sich
eindeutig dagegen wir sehen atomkraft
nach wie vor als nicht nachhaltig an
künftige generationen dürfen durch unser
heutiges handeln nicht über gebühr
belastet werden ähnlich kritisch
äußerten sich heute weitere wohnhäuser
mit einem ökolabel für kernkraft und gas
würde die eu ihrer vorreiterrolle beim
thema nachhaltigkeit nicht gerecht das
grüne label ist an bedingungen geknüpft
welcher sein dass der neue gaswerke
müssen technisch auf dem neuesten stand
sein und im prinzip kohlekraftwerke
überflüssig machen also gas als
kleineres übel und eine atomkraftwerk
ist in der taxonomie logik vor allem
dann grün wenn bis spätestens 20 50 ein
konkreter plan vorliegt wie der hoch
radioaktive müll entsorgt werden soll
das letzte wort aber ist noch nicht
gesprochen zahlreiche klagen zeichnet
sich bereits ab vielen dank nach
frankfurt
zu den lottozahlen die lauten
126 38 41 47 48 superzahl 6 alle angaben
wie immer ohne gewähr
am abend ist die fußball wm der frauen
im britischen manchester gestartet über
71.000 zuschauer und damit so viele wie
noch nie zuvor kamen für die feierliche
eröffnungszeremonie und dem ersten
anpfiff ins old trafford stadium auftakt
spiel england gegen österreich für die
deutsche nationalmannschaft wird es dann
am freitag gegen dänemark ernst zu sehen
hier im zdf um 21 uhr
in der ukraine sind bereits viele
kriegsverbrechen russischer soldaten
dokumentiert und es werden immer mehr
ein furchtbarer verdacht auch
vergewaltigungen könnten als kriegswaffe
eingesetzt werden das auslandsjournal
geht demnach gleich nach uns und das war
unsere schwierige welt an diesem
mittwoch danke für ihr interesse morgen
sind hier marietta slomka und ich bin
auch noch hier morgen und noch der
hinweis auf unser heute-journal update
heute gegen drei fächer in allen vom
gesamten team einen angenehmen haben
testen
[Musik]
schon goethe und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter das ist sind die daten vom
deutschen wetterdienst und jeder balken
stellt einig juni monat da seit 1881 und
sie sehen vor allem in den 80er jahren
wurden die juni monate allmählich immer
wärmer die zu kühlen die gab es kaum
noch und dann nahmen die temperaturen
immer weiter zu die durchschnittswerte
in den juni monaten wurden immer größer
und der letzte balken hier ist 2022 und
landet auf dem sechsten platz schauen
wir das aktuelle wetter und da ist regen
gleich segen muss man sagen und der
kommt aus dem norden war ja viel zu
trocken letzter zeit diese kaltfront
bringt 20 liter auf den quadratmeter
einer kommenden nacht und morgen etwa
genauso viel tagsüber schauen wir in die
nacht wunder gibt es schauer und
gewitter die von norden her weiter
richtung mitte ziehen im süden ist es
trocken und die tiefsten temperaturen
liegen bei sieben grad am alpenrand und
16 grad ganz im westen deutschlands
morgen am vormittag schon schauer und
gewitter bis zur mitte und südlich des
mains sogar ganz im süden ist es erst
mal trocken zum nachmittag wandert das
ganze weiter südwärts und vor allem an
der nordsee gibt es auch stürmische böen
tja und weiterhin schauer und gewitter
damit müssen sie rechnen nur im
südwesten bleibt es trocken bei höchsten
temperaturen von 25 grad im südwesten
und 17 grad im vogtland häufig werte um
die 20 grad marke und teilweise darunter
die kommenden tage am freitag nur im
süden schauer sonst trocken bei 26 grad
danach ein wenig wärmer damit ein
schöner abend